you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
do you have any
are there any like just burning things
that you think the world has to know
about skeletons
that we haven't covered yet
i want everyone to know that like
that scale that our skeletons are
absolutely amazing because
they are living
lattices they are living structures and
while we're not the first to invent
skeletons i mean sponges have skeletons
crabs technically have skeletons you
know exoskeletons
we're not the first to invent
mineralizing something to support our
bodies or to support our muscles as
vertebrates we are not but we are
definitely the first to
invent a living structure that adapts to
what we do
in real time
in like our lives because
snails have a skeleton and sponges have
a skeleton but they can't remodel it
once it's made it's dead
but ours listens to us and changes with
our needs which
i think is what makes our skeletons
really unique and i think that's why you
picked up on
remodeling as like your main topic
because it's such a it's such an
interesting topic
it is what makes us special
yeah i think we have this false idea
that a skeleton is just like a dead rock
inside of us right um bone is
but it just
i mean you were saying that your your
bones rebuild themselves
until you're like seven yeah i know well
even after you basically get a fresh new
skeleton every seven to ten years
because just because of you know the
calculation goes like i think you
remodel like
however many grams of bone each day and
then they just scaled it up to time and
how much in your skeleton
and so
our skeletons are working really hard
for us to make sure that you know you
don't have the same bone that you're
you're born with because it has all the
micro cracks every step you've ever
taken everything you've ever lifted
creates strain in your skeleton and
creates all these micro cracks and it
wants you to have
fresh new bones to work with every few
years so certain areas of our body
remodel faster than others depending on
the strains and
probably the best thing you can do for
your skeleton is eat right see some sun
and uh
just take a walk every now and again and
it'll serve you well
that's cool
well
yara thank you for coming on this is
amazing seriously this was this was
better is it everything you wanted it's
better than i thought it'd be yes
um
i
i guess my message for um for people on
on bones would be to uh
a lot of people tell kids not to look at
you know the dead body on the the dead
cat on the side of the road and stuff
like that
if if the kid's interested let them look
yeah make make them poke it
yeah let them poke it yeah
maybe use a stick if it's really rotten
fine but if it's a little squishy makes
sense but yeah i mean encourage
encourage curiosity into osteology and i
mean all natural things has definitely
always been my message i'm glad you
agree yeah
well thank you this has been great
yeah absolutely no it was really fun and
i love talking with bones
and that is it my friends
yara haridi i do recommend that you
follow her on twitter if you're on
twitter i don't know if she has facebook
and all that other stuff too but
her twitter is pretty good she's always
posting cool stuff on there so check
that out
well that's it for this clip but don't
worry i post clips regularly and every
thursday i post completely fresh content
make sure you're subscribed
liking and commenting is also welcome